what do you do when you're golfing Fox
she I don't think she does this must be
really embarrassing cuz she won't do it
around me
hi I'm Doug Daisy what did you
birthday's okay Jimmy Joe do your
night-night
June 21st hands in we're all June babies
let's say June baby on three K one two
three well it's apparently what I have
it's like a body that looks like that
guy's definitely has kids a little bit
of a belly you know a little bit of love
handles jiggles a little bit when you
try to dance what do you do when your
girlfriend fonts she I don't think she
does I've never heard her fart and if
you ask her she'll tell you that she
never has I would be if I'd love to hear
it but I mean who knows what it sounds
like me this must be really embarrassing
because she won't do it around me I
think it plays music I think music and
glitter comes out what's your best turn
up line
I say do your feet hurt cuz you've been
walking around in my dreams all night
did it work did I chat up here was your
first levity crush uh-huh my first
celebrity crush was a girl who was a
singer and she had red hair
and her name was Tiffany and I was
smitten because she had a music video on
TV that I saw maybe the Queen that'd be
pretty cool
I'd like to meet the Queen can I do you
know her you do yeah would you introduce
me to Queen Elizabeth okay I understand
Shasha best dance crew my best dance
move okay
that's with my hands it goes like this
and then it goes into a dab you know
what a dab is right there you go very
good you want try with me
[Music]
oh well I blew it I'm sorry
what cenotes then okay have ever done I
recently found a whole bunch of candy
beneath my son's pillow he'd been
sneaking it off into bed and eating it
at night without asking well that was
really nice
thank you guys it's such a pleasure to
meet you did I do okay yes all right